PROFESSOR: We've seen
a lot of functions
in introductory calculus-- trig
functions, rational functions,
exponentials, logs and so on.
I don't know whether
your calculus course
has included a general
discussion of functions.
The old fashioned ones didn't,
and we will go into that
now in this segment.
And we're going to be
interpreting functions
as a special case
of binary relations.
So let's just say what
a binary relation is.
A binary relation is
a mathematical object
that associates
elements of one set
called the domain with
elements of another set
called the codomain.
And I'm going to give
you a bunch of examples
of binary relations
in a short moment,
but let's just talk
about what they're for
and what their role is.
So they may be familiar to
you as computer scientists
if you've worked with any
relational databases like SQL
or MySQL.
MySQL.
And we'll see an
example that indicates
where the original ideas behind
those relational databases
came from.
But even more
fundamental, relations
are one of the most basic
mathematical abstractions right
after sets, and they
play a role everywhere.
We're going to be
looking in later lectures
at special kinds
of binary relations
like equivalence relations
and partial orders
and numerical congruences.
But today, we're going
to set up the machinery
to be using binary
relations for counting,
which will be another important
application in this class.
So let's look at an example.
And I'm going to take one that's
close to home-- the registered
for relation, which is a
relation between students--
that's going to be the
domain, in this case, four
students, Jason, Joan, Yihui,
and Adam-- and four subjects.
As a coincidence, 6.042,
003, 012, and 004.
And the relation R is
going to be indicated
by arrows which show just
which students are associated
with which subjects,
meaning that they're
registered for that subject.
So if we look at
Jason, we can see
that there's a particular arrow
connecting Jason and 6.042.
And what that tells us is that
Jason is registered for 6.042.
Now, there's a
bunch of notations
that are used with respect
to binary relations.
So let's look at some.
One way to write
it is if you think
of the relation R
as an equality sign
or a less than sign,
where it's normally
written in the middle
of the two things
that it's connecting, as in
this example-- Jason R 6.042.
That would be called
infix notation.
Sometimes it's written
as a binary predicate-- R
of Jason comma 6.042.
That would be kind
of prefix notation
where the relation or
operator comes first.
And then if you start
being a little closer
to the formal definition of
what a binary relation is,
you could say that the
ordered pair Jason 6.042
is a member of the relation.
If you wanted to
be really precise,
you would say that
it was a member
of the graph of the relation.
And I'll come back
and elaborate further
on what the graph
of a relation is
and what this ordered
pairs businesses.
But for now, just let's
continue with this example.
And a basic concept
with relations
is the idea of the image
of a bunch of domain
elements under the relation.
So you can think of the
relation as an operator
that applies to domain
elements or even sets
of domain elements.
So if I write R of Jason,
that defines the subjects
that Jason is registered for.
So looking at the picture,
R is not a function.
So that there may be more
than one subject, as is
you'd expect for a student to be
registered for multiple courses
at MIT.
So Jason in this diagram is
registered for 6.042 and 6.012
as indicated by the
highlighted two connection
arrows, which we've made red.
Which means that R
of Jason is that set
of two courses that
he's associated with
or that are associated
with him-- that he's
registered 6.042 and 6.012.
So at this point,
we've applied R
to one domain element--
one student Jason.
But the interesting
case is when you apply R
to a bunch of students.
So the general
setup is that if x
is a set of students-- a subset
of the domain, which we've
been showing in green--
then if I apply R to X,
it gives me all the
subjects that they're
taking among them-- all the
subjects that any one of them
is taking.
Let's take a look at an example.
Well, another way to say
it I guess is that R of X
is everything in R that
relates to things in X.
So if I look at
Jason and Yihui and I
want to know what do
they connect to under R--
these are the subjects
that Jason or Yihui
is registered for.
The way I'd find that is by
looking at the arrow diagram,
and I'd find that Jason
is taking 042 and 012.
And Yihui is taking 012 and 004.
So between them, they're
taking three courses.
So R of Jason, Yihui is
in fact 042, 012, and 004.
So another way to understand
this idea of the image of a set
R of X is that X is a
set of points in the set
that you're starting
with called the domain.
And R of X is going to be all of
the endpoints in the other set,
the codomain, that start at X.
If I said that as a statement
in formal logic or in set theory
with logical notation,
I would say that R of X
is the set of j in
subjects such that there
is a d in X such that dRj.
So what that's exactly
saying that dRj
says that d is the starting
point in the domain.
d is a student.
j is a subject.
dRj means there's an arrow
that goes from student
d to subject j.
And we're collecting the set of
those j's that started some d.
So an arrow from X
goes to j is what
exists at d an X. dRj means--
written in logic notation--
it's really talking about
the endpoints of arrows,
and that's a nice way
to think about it.
But you ought to be
able also to retreat
to give a nice, crisp
set theoretic definition
without reference to
pictures if need be.
So that's an official
definition of the image under R.
Let's turn now to an
operation on relations which
converts one relation
into another relation
called the inverse of
R. And the inverse of R
is what you get by
turning the arrows around.
So let's look at the
relation R, which
is the registered for
relation going from d students
to j subjects.
And then if I look at
R inverse, R inverse
I could think of as the
registers relation-- 6.042
registers Jason, and 6.012
registers Jason and Yihui.
It's a funny usage of the word,
but I needed something short
that would fit on the slide.
So registers is basically
turning the arrows backwards of
is registered for.
And now I can apply
the definition of image
to R inverse in a useful way.
But just to be crisp about
what we're doing here
is formally our
inverse is gotten
by flipping the role of the
domain and the codomain.
So we have that dRj if
and only if jR inverse d.
So let's look at R
inverse of 6.012.
What that's going to
mean is all the students
that are taking 6.012.
So we start off at 6.012, and
we go back to all the students
that are registered for it.
It's Jason and Yihui again.
And so our inverse of
6.012 is Jason and Yihui.
Our inverse of 6.012 and 6.003?
Well, it's same deal.
Let's look at 6.003 and 6.012
and look at all the students
that are registered
for either one of them.
Now its Jason, Joan, and Yihui
shown by those red arrows--
all the arrows coming out of
those two courses, 003 and 012.
And so our inverse of 003
and 012 is that set of three
students-- Jason,
Joan, and Yihui.
And in general,
when you start off
with a bunch of subjects--
a bunch of elements--
of the codomain and you
apply R inverse to it,
it's called the inverse
image of the Y under R.
Well, let's look at the
set J of all the subjects
and think about what
is R inverse of J. What
does it mean?
Well, R inverse of J
is all the students
that are registered
for some subject
at all, which is a
good thing to have.
So now, I can start using
these sets to make assertions
about my database that
can be useful to know.
So for example, if I want
to say that every student is
registered for some
subject-- which, of course,
they are-- what I
would say is that D,
the set of all students, is
a subset of R inverse of J.
So this concise set theoretic
containment statement--
d is a subset of
R inverse of J--
is a slick way of writing
the precise statement that
says that all the students are
registered for some subject.
Now, happens not to
be true by the way.
Because if you look
back at that example,
Adam was not registered
for a subject.
So we're not claiming
that this is true,
but simply that
there's a nice way
to express it using
images and containment.
Let's look at a
different relation
that we could call
the advises relation.
So the advises relation's
going to have codomain
the same set of students d, but
it's going to have as a domain
the set of professors.
And I've written down
the initials of five
prominent professors
minus at the top--
and you may recognize
some of the others.
But it doesn't really
matter if you don't.
And the advises
relation V is going
to be indicated by those arrows.
So in particular,
it shows that ARM
is the adviser of Jason,
Joan, Yihui, and Adam,
which he happens to be.
FTL is an adviser
of Joan and Yihui.
So Joan has two advisers
because she's a double major.
Yihui does as well.
And Adam does as well now
that I look at this example.
So if I look at in particular
now the advisees of FTL or TLP,
I'm looking at V of the set
consisting of FTL and TLP.
And it's going to be
Joan, Yihui, and Adam.
So taking the image
of FTL and TLP--
that's the set of advisees of
either of those two professors,
I get this set of
three students--
Joan, Yihui, and Adam.
Well, that's a set of students,
and the registered relation
applies to a set of students.
So let's do that.
If I now apply R
to Joan and Yihui
and Adam, what I'm
getting is the subjects
that they're registered for.
So this is called composing R
and V. I've applied V and them
I'm applying R to the result.
In this case, R of
V of FTL and TLP
is the same as R of
Joan, Yihui, and Adam.
It's the courses that any of
them are taking, and it's 003,
012, and 004.
So the way to understand
this R of V in general
is you start off with any set
X of professors in the domain.
You take V of W-- are the
advisees that they have have--
and then you take
R of the advisees,
and you get the subjects
that the advisees are taking.
So R of V of X is the subjects
that advisees of X are taking,
are registered for.
Well, we can abstract
that out and call
this the composition of R and
V. It's defined the same way
that functional composition is.
So R of V is the relation and
the images of that relation.
The images of a set of
professors under R of V
is defined to be apply V to
X and then apply R to V of X.
And it's again, called the
composition of R and V.
What it means now is that two
things are related by R of V.
It relates professors
and subjects.
And it says that a
professor in a subject
are related if the professor
has an advisee-- some advisee--
in that subject.
p for a professor.
Composition of R with
V. j for a subject
holds if and only if
professor p has an advisee
registered in subject j.
Let's see how you figure
that kind of thing out.
So I'm going to draw
the V relation which
goes from p professors
to D students
and then the R relation
that goes from D students
to J subjects.
And by showing
them in this way, I
can understand the
composition of R and V
as following two arrows.
You start off, say, at ARM, and
you follow a V arrow from ARM
to his advisee, Yihui.
Then you follow another
arrow from Yihui to 6.012,
and you discover, hey,
ARM has an advisee in--
So now we can say that
professor ARM is in the relation
R composed with V with
6.012 because of this path
ARM has Yihui as an advisee, and
Yihui is registered for 6.012.
And this relation R
o V, we figured out,
is the relation
that the professor
has an advisee in the subject.
So in general,
what we can say is
that a professor p is
in the R o V relation
to j if and only
if-- and here we're
going to state it in formal
logical notation, which
really applies in
general, not just
to this particular example.
So the definition
of R composed with V
is the p R composed
with Vj means
there's a D that connects
p and j through V and D,
in particular that
there's a D such that pVd,
which means there's a
V arrow from p to to d.
And dRJ-- there's an
R arrow from d to j.
For some, d.
By the way, there's
a technicality here
that when you write the
formula pVd and dRj, following
the diagram where you
start with V on the left
and follow a V arrow
and then and R arrow,
it's natural to think
of them as written
in left to right order of
which you apply first V R.
But of course, that's not
the way composition works.
When you apply, one function--
R to V to something,
you're applying V first.
And you write it on the right.
So R o V is written like
function composition
where V applies first,
but the logical statement,
the natural way to
write it, is to follow
the way the picture works.
And D, Vs, and Rs get reversed.
So watch out for that confusion.
Well, I want to introduce
one more relation to flesh
out this example, and that'll
be the teaches relation.
So the teaches relation
is going to have--
as domain professors, again--
and it's codomain, subjects.
And it's simply going to
tell us who's teaching what.
So here we're going to see
that ARM is teaching 6.042,
as you well know.
And FTL is teaching 6.042,
two which he does frequently
but not this term.
And now I can again use
my relational operators
to start making assertions
about these people
and relations involving
teaching and advisees.
And a useful way to do that
is by applying set operations
to the relations because I
can think of the relations
as being that set of arrows.
So suppose I wanted to make
some statement that a professor
should not teach their
own advisee because it's
too much power for one person
to have over a student.
This is not true, by the way.
It's common for professors
to teach advisees,
but there are other
kinds of rules
about dual relationships between
supervisory relationships
and personal relationships.
But anyway, let's
say if we can say
that profs should not teach
anyone one that they're
advising.
Well, if we were saying that in
logical notation, what we would
say is that for every
professor and subject,
it's not the case
that the professor has
an advisee in subject
j and the professor
is teaching subject j.
So that's how you
would say it in logic,
but there's a very
slick way to say it
without all the formulas
and the quantifiers.
I could just say that T, the
relationship of his teaching,
intersected with
the relationship
of has an advisee in
the subject is empty.
There is no pair of professor
and subject that is in both T
and in R of V.
And this bottom
expression here gives you
a sense of the
concise way that you
can express queries and
assertions about the database
using a combination of
relational operators
and set operators.
Another way to say it
by the way-- there's
a general set theoretic
fact-- is the way
to say that T and R of
V intersected is empty
is to say that the set T and the
set R of V, whatever they are,
have no points in common.
An equivalent way to
say that is that one set
is contained in the
complement of the other set.
So I could equally well have
said this as R composed with V
is a subset of not T.
Well, let's step back
now and summarize
what we've done by example
and say a little bit
about how it works in general.
So as I said, a binary
relation-- and we'll
start to be slightly more
formal now-- a binary relation
R from a set A to a set B
associates elements of A
with elements of B.
And there's a picture
of a general set
A called the domain
and a general set B
called the codomain.
And R is given by those arrows.
Well, what exactly are arrows?
Well, if you're going
to formalize arrows,
the set of them is what's
called the graph of R.
So technically, a relation
really has three parts.
It's not to be identified
with just its arrows.
A relation has a
domain and codomain
and some bunch of arrows
going from the domain
to the codomain.
The arrows can be
formalized by saying all
that matters about an arrow is
where it begins where it ends
because it's just
designed to reflect
an association between
an element of the domain
and an element of the codomain.
So technically, the arrows
are just ordered pairs.
And in this case, there are
three arrows-- one from A
to b 2.
And so you see at the bottom of
the slide an ordered pair a 1,
b 2.
Another arrow goes
for a 1 to b 4.
So you see the
ordered pair a 1, b 4.
And the final arrow is a 3, b 4.
And you see that pair.
So all the language
about arrows is really
talking about ordered pairs.
It's just that the
geometric image
of these diagrams
and their arrows
makes a lot of
properties much clearer.
So the range of R is
an important concept
that comes up regularly
and tends to be
a little confusing for people.
The range of R is
simply the elements
with arrows coming
in from R. It's
all of the elements that
are hit by an arrow that
starts in the domain.
So it's really R of the
domain is the range of R.
Now, notice that
this is typically not
equal to the whole codomain.
Let's look at this example.
Here, the range
of R-- the points
that are hit by elements of
A under R, namely just b 2
and b 4.
The codomain has elements b
1 and b 3 that are missing
and that are not in the range.
Well, as I said, functions are
a special case of relations.
So let's just look at that.
A function, F, from
a set A to a set B
is a relation which
associates with each element
in the domain-- each element
little a and the domain capital
A-- with at most one
element of the codomain B.
So this one element, if it
exists, is called F of a.
It's the image of the element
a under the relation F,
but what's special about it is
that F of a contains at most
one element.
So let's just look
at an example again.
A way to say that a
relation is a function
is to look at all of the points
on the left in the domain
and make sure that none of them
have more than one arrow coming
out.
Well, in this picture, there are
a couple of violations of that.
There are a couple
points on the left in A
that have more than
one arrow coming out.
[? There's ?] our two bad edges.
But if I erase those, now
I'm left with a function.
And sure enough, there's at
most one arrow coming out
of each of the points on the
left in A. Some of the points
have no arrows coming out.
That's fine.
And so for those green
points with an arrow out,
there's a unique F of the
green point equal to a magenta
point in B that's uniquely
determined by the functional
relation F, which may
not be defined for all
of the green points if they
don't have any arrow coming out
of them.
So function means less than or
equal to 1 arrow coming out.
So if we set this
formally without talking
about the arrows,
one way is simply
to say that a
relation is a function
if the size of F of little a is
less than or equal to 1 for all
of the domain elements A.
And a more elementary
way to say it
using just the language
of relations and equality
and Boolean
connectives is to say
that if a is connected
to two things
by F-- if aFb AND aFb
prime-- then in fact
b is equal to b prime.
And that wraps up functions.